in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I take app engines new scheduling
flags for a ride will we buck the
performance trend stay tuned to find out
now one of the nice aspects of the cloud
being a platform is that over time it'll
grow change and improve itself which is
exactly why we're talking about app
engine instance count again see since
our episode last year the App Engine
team rolled out a brand new scheduling
system to help you get even more control
over how and when App Engine spins up
instances so of course I wanted to dive
in kick the tires and see how some of
the new settings works but first I
wanted to get a baseline read on how the
scheduler responds in the same tests
that we use last time once again our
server code is pretty simple it's just a
simulation of a CPU intensive
application obviously if you have a four
second response time you've got bigger
problems to worry about as a baseline
here is 1k queries per second which the
previous scheduler shows differences
between the new and now we can see that
without touching any settings the new
scheduler is already performing just a
little bit better for my contrived
scenario which is good because it means
that without lifting a finger we get a
little better on instance counts next is
something I've been interested in for a
while
min and Max instance settings max
instances of course defines the upper
limit on the number of instances you can
have which is helpful to control your
costs while min instances ensures that
after deployment there's always a
certain number of instances running so
but before you set this flag make sure
you take into account how your minimum
instance account interacts with your
idle instance account since they are two
very different concepts and you don't
want a lot of spare instances lying
around when you don't need them out make
sure you check out the article in the
description below for more details on
that
anyhow next up is the target throughput
utilization flag which sets a threshold
for the number of concurrent requests
after which more instances will be
started to handle the traffic this flag
works hand in hand with max concurrent
requests to determine your true number
of requests per instance for throughput
heavy applications lowering this value
will result in more instances being spun
up it's you handled the work while
increasing this value will let each in
better handle the connections and in
most cases should reduce incidence count
now finally is the target CPU
utilization flag this flag defines the
CPU utilization ratio which defines when
a new instance should be spun up or
perhaps a better way to say it if your
app is CPU bound then this is the
parameter you tweak to optimize between
performance and costs since lowering and
raising it can impact how many instances
you spin up in order to handle the
workload with an improved scheduler and
a new set of settings App Engine gives
you much better controls to better
balance between performance and costs
which in my humble opinion is always the
spot you want to be in if you'd like to
know more about these tests check out
the article linked in the description
below and don't forget to check out the
rest of the cloud performance Atlas
content because when it comes to
performance every millisecond counts